- What do a 5G network in Ethiopia,
a vaccine manufacturing plant in India
and a clean energy project in South Africa
have in common?
They are the battlegrounds
in the US government's efforts
to counter Chinese
influence around the world.
They call it Build Back Better World.
- The Build Back Better World project
should be high quality and high standards.
- This is not gonna be
easy for the US government.
China has been in this
game for eight years now
and they've committed more
than $400 billion for projects.
The biggest US development agency
has only $60 billion available.
So they're cobbling together more money
with other countries.
So these are still really early days
but this competition
is starting to heat up.
To understand where this all got started,
you have to go back to Beijing in 2013.
That's when the Chinese
government pitched this project
to go to developing countries
and build them infrastructure.
They called this effort the
Belt and Road Initiative.
And the deal was this.
They would go to a developing country
and offer them a loan for
an infrastructure project.
And then they would send
a Chinese company there
to build the railway, port or whatever.
So the Chinese government
called this a win-win deal.
Countries like the US and its allies said
this wasn't a good deal.
The interest rates were really high.
So what happened since the
Biden administration took over
was they've developed an alternative
to the Belt and Road project.
They say the deals would
be much more transparent
and have better quality, better standards
and would not indebt these
developing countries.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Stu] What the US and
its allies are trying to do
is not only challenge
Chinese influence abroad
but they're also trying to pair it
with some of their other priorities,
including climate change.
- The Build Back Better
World is gonna show
that we can grow our economies,
fight climate change
and leave a better,
cleaner, more livable planet
for all of our children.
- [Stu] At the UN Climate
Change Conference in Glasgow,
the US and its allies announced
a new clean energy project
in South Africa.
- I hope it will be a blueprint
for similar partnerships
with other countries.
- They also said it signaled
to the world saying hey,
China is not the only country
that will fund and build your projects.
Come to the US, come to
the UK, come to France.
We have these offers for you too.
We'll give you loans
but we'll also help you find a contractor
to do these projects.
We're open for business.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Now, these are really early days
and the US hasn't always followed through
on its friendliness,
even though it says it
wants to be friendly.
And they're gonna have
some challenges ahead
in rebuilding relationships with countries
like France, for instance.
So it remains to be seen whether
these developing countries
will actually take a serious look
at the American offers.
But this is gonna be a really
interesting competition
between the US and its allies, and China
to see who can win more influence,
who can build more infrastructure projects
in the developing world.
(lively music)